acknowledging that's the case here in
this but men haven't changed just
because of social parameters
but the thing is the social the social
parameters have changed to appease women
yeah and so so met but men have remained
the same they they want the same things
women have changed no but as i said the
social parameters have changed so the
social parameters for men have changed
and the social parameters for women have
changed what do you mean what do you
define social parameters so for example
materialistically men are supposed to
still provide be able to provide a
higher rate at a faster rate from a
younger age
this is a social parameter change it's
not realistic it is set out by women i
agree but with the women with the ladies
now a lot of us we have a materialistic
approach to how we view men
and when they can't provide that we get
upset we don't actually look at like
what you said the characteristics the
moralistic values we don't look at
actually when i look at this man do i
see family because a lot of people they
they they want
uh
financial benefits but they don't
actually want family what does it make
women the problem then yeah
because men are the same like if
anything more is expected of men is less
is given to them
sorry
i think that um we're getting married a
lot later in life and that's
you know part of it so like for example
maybe 50 years ago getting married at
age 16 to 18 might not have been a big
deal whereas now when uh when a
a young woman wants to get married at 21
it's like are you ready for this you
know have you finished uni yeah have you
traveled there's there's so much that
women are doing that they weren't doing
50 years ago that they're doing now and
it's it's affecting the the age that
people get married so doesn't make women
a problem
i never said women
but then
did you not say they were that they were
the prize
i said where the prize when were younger
oh yeah yeah before 40.
and i'm curious i haven't heard much
from you what do you think because i
don't agree okay i feel like men's
problem
tell me why tell me why because
i'm young isn't it so
i'm just thinking when i was younger
women were always the one
um more involved in the relationships
men were always the one cheating
treating the woman wrong so that now i'm
21. all of us are tired at the age of
20. why did you pick them
um
if you if you if women hate being
cheated on why'd you pick the ones that
cheat girls know you know early on that
they're going to cheat on you you know
you know damn well
you know
you know
you know damn well you know damn well
that that guy is capable of cheating so
how that's how is that on him when you
picked him you know what
after i finished with the guys that
cheat i was not like let me go to a nice
guy even now but now you're left over
for him oh
but i was only like 18. so yeah look i'm
not i'm not saying i'm just saying
that's how men view it we 18. yeah i
mean i mean
i don't i don't know i'm not gonna ask
like what
i'm just saying like i'm saying this is
common so so you're young but i'm saying
this is common where girls will go
through the bad boys and the cheaters
until they're 27 28 and then come to the
nice guys who they've been rejecting the
last decade right and saying take me
oh i'm ready for you and they're like
well
now you're you're chad's leftovers
and i say that but it's like how is that
on them when we pick them because one
out of three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the last year so
there's a lot of men that won't cheat on
you you just don't want them
okay
look look in your friend zone or go to
go to
you guys don't have time do you guys
have taco bell here you do
go to go to taco bell ask the guy out
behind the counter i bet you he won't
cheat on you
come on don't do that go ask him out
i won't do that
what you know how we're talking about
the whole team don't we feel like back
in the day there was no social media
like they were writing letters
everyone's covered up from head to toe i
feel like because now there's more
temptation even further guys because
women because women because yeah because
women got worse yeah because because men
will do anything to get laid
literally literally anything so if
if we required marriage to get laid we
would all be married
if we if we required a fancy date so our
values of lesson that's what you're
saying
i would say women have thrown it at them
yeah like we're less valuable to men
because men are the same
can we ask the men that what's valuable
to them that would be yeah go ahead go
ahead start with them
like what do you mean like
what what does value mean to you in a
woman
uh femininity
uh submission mm-hmm um
being my piece
that's the key one yeah it's important
so important i love that one yeah that's
it yeah i would say literally the same
stuff as him but literally the same um
being feminine
peace of mind um being able to look at
your self as well and have self
development like be able to actually say
your accountability yeah you know what i
mean and being able to have a
conversation about stuff like if there's
an issue which some a lot of people
can't do to be honest so also question
do you guys value purity
would you guys would you guys rather
have a girl that slept with a hundred
guys or one guy
okay
okay let's let's say would you rather
have a girl that slept with 10 guys or
50.
okay okay so you value purity yeah yeah
definitely okay yeah
same thing yeah yeah okay what about you
same as me boy
you know what's crazy um that you're
talking about purely i went into
someone's tick tock live but it's about
purely and she was talking about andrew
tate and you know he said the same kind
of thing yeah with girls sleeping with
loads of people and the girls sleeping
with less um and she said
well i don't really care what guys think
i'll sleep with whoever i want and as
much people as i want there's nothing
you could do about it
in my head i just thought this is the
problem because i don't know if there's
like something
but they will still get wifed so
yeah
but no i don't agree with it i don't
agree with that i think that's where we
tapped but that's crazy but but those
kind of girls sorry but those kind of
girls i feel like i strongly disagree
it's mad because you get like let's say
i've seen good guys that will go for
that and i'm just there like what i'll
tell you why they're the nice guys
picking up the leftovers and the problem
is those girls don't respect him because
they actually want the dude that cheated
whenever whenever a girl whenever a girl
has a guy that she always complains
about that's who she loved the most
it's not it's not the one that she
doesn't really talk about he said he was
such a good boyfriend he was she didn't
like him
you're laughing you know it's true
and so those guys pick them up at 30 and
then they'll still cheat with the
the guy they really wanted
or wish they were with him yeah what
dumb fool pretty much so
that's why that's why like
virgins should be preferred like if you
if you slept with one person and you get
married what is your chance of a happy
marriage do you think
i heard your podcast you actually
mentioned this all the time but then do
you know what i find crazy though you
also get the guys that complain that oh
my day she didn't know what she was
doing in bed and then now he started
cheating five years down the line
because she's so dead and also no wait
no wait no wait no i've heard a guy say
we actually weren't sexually compatible
that's the reason why because he was
probably too much of a freak most girls
can't have good sex seriously
most girls are not good at six how do
you know
[Laughter]
no honestly most girls just take wood
let's be real like what if it's your
partner would you not teach them and
would you not
would you like not like grow like as in
you're teaching her what you like she's
teaching you what she likes of course
it's contextual um i don't think you can
be the partner and not
expect her to like certain things but
that's what i'm saying certain guys
they're just overly freaky because most
men are very simple to please you just
blog
straight
but
where guys would prefer a girl they
could teach versus because if she's
coming in a freak he's like where did
you learn